en el vídeo anterior mostramos que esta
es la fórmula para el área de un
triángulo que tiene lados de medidas a b
y c y además afirme que esta fórmula era
equivalente a la fórmula de heron lo que
vamos a hacer en este vídeo es ver que
efectivamente esto se reduce a la
expresión sencilla que te mostré hace un
par de vídeos y para esto vamos a
utilizar el teorema de pitágoras y un
poco de álgebra espeluznante pero no te
preocupes al final va a ser muy
satisfactorio ver como algo tan
complicado se reduce a algo tan simple
muy bien déjame empezar con este un
medio de c este un medio d se lo voy a
meter a esta raíz y para eso tengo que
hacer lo siguiente tengo que notar que
un medio de c es lo mismo es igual a la
raíz cuadrada de c medios elevado al
cuadrado la raíz y el cuadrado se
cancelan y esto de aquí es igual a la
raíz cuadrada de cea al cuadrado
dividido entre 4 muy bien vamos a
utilizar esto para reescribir esta
expresión de esta forma tenemos que el
área
a ponerle nada más a es igual a y en vez
de escribir la raíz por todas partes
déjame simplemente poner aquí raíz raíz
para poder meter lo demás en un
paréntesis entonces área es igual a la
raíz de y aquí dentro del paréntesis
tengo que poner un medio de c pero aquí
adentro
o séase cuadrado entre 4 cuadrada entre
4 x esta expresión y esta expresión
déjame marcarla en color verde para que
el álgebra quede más bonita entonces
sería al cuadrado menos se cuadrada más
a cuadrada menos be cuadrada dividido
entre dos veces c eso de ahí elevado al
cuadrado y cerramos este paréntesis de
acá y el paréntesis de la raíz muy bien
ahora lo que voy a hacer es distribuir
este ese cuadrado entre cuatro en este
paréntesis de esta forma nos quedaría
que el área es igual es igual a la raíz
la raíz de sería se cuadrado entre 4 por
cuadrada lo voy a poner en verde se
cuadrada por a cuadrada dividido entre 4
eso es este por este menos menos se
cuadrado entre 4 se cuadra da entre 4 /
esta expresión déjame desarrollarla la
voy a poner como el numerador al
cuadrado se se cuadrada más a cuadrada
menos b cuadrada eso de ahí elevado al
cuadrado dividido entre 2 sea al
cuadrado o sea 4 c cuadrado muy bien voy
a cerrar el paréntesis de acá y vamos a
simplificar un poco observa que se
cuadrada se cancela con c cuadrada aquí
está en el numerador y aquí en el
denominador 4x4 es 16 pero en vez de
poner 16 déjame ponerlo como 4 al
cuadrado
ahorita va a saber por qué entonces
vamos a pasar este renglón nos quedaría
que el área es igual a la raíz a la raíz
de la raíz de y observa esto es una
expresión al cuadrado esto es separa
entre 2 al cuadrado entonces lo voy a
poner así
por a entre 2 al cuadrado y a eso le voy
a restar y ve que esto de acá también es
una expresión al cuadrado por eso puse 4
al cuadrado sería c cuadrada masa
cuadrada menos b cuadrada entre 4 y todo
eso elevado al cuadrado
lo voy a apuntar por acá ese cuadrado de
cuadrada más a cuadrada menos b cuadrada
dividido entre 4 y todo eso elevado al
cuadrado al cuadrado muy bien déjame
cerrar el paréntesis de la raíz y
observemos que ahora tenemos la resta de
dos cuadrados tenemos una expresión de
la forma x al cuadrado menos y al
cuadrado y eso es una diferencia de
cuadrados que sabemos cómo factorizar x
al cuadrado menos llega al cuadrado es
igual a x +
x x y entonces vamos a aplicar esta
fórmula de hecho la vamos a utilizar
repetidas veces así que tenga en mente
aquí este sería x separa entre 2 y esta
expresión dentro del paréntesis sería y
de esta forma nos queda que esto es
igual es igual igual a la raíz
y aquí vamos a poner x + quedaría c por
a dividido entre dos más se cuadrada más
a cuadrada menos b cuadrada dividido
entre cuatro y eso x x ya que sería
separa dividido entre 2 - se cuadrada
más a cuadrada menos b cuadrada entre 4
muy bien vamos a seguir trabajando con
esta expresión lo que vamos a hacer
ahora es efectuar esta suma y esta resta
de fracciones vamos a hacerlo parte por
parte le voy a poner aquí raíz de y
vamos primero con esta suma de
fracciones de fracciones el denominador
común es 4 tenemos que encontrar un
denominador común para para para poder
sumar la verdad entonces notamos que es
4 así que nos quedaría poner la rayita
un poco más acá nos quedaría aquí el 4
para pasar esta fracción a cuartos hay
que multiplicar el numerador por 2 sería
dos veces sea
más se cuadrada masa cuadrada menos b
cuadrada muy bien y voy a hacer lo mismo
con esta expresión también el
denominador común es 4
multiplicamos este numerador por 2 nos
quedaría 2 veces sea menos se cuadrada a
que hay que tener cuidado
- se cuadrada menos a cuadrada menos al
cuadrado más b cuadrada b cuadrada
excelente y aquí lo que tenemos que
hacer es darnos cuenta que aparece una
expresión especial estar acá 12 a más e
cuadrada más a cuadrada esta expresión
es más b al cuadrado a más elevado al
cuadrado y está acá es algo parecido
pero cuidando los signos sería menos
- ce elevado al cuadrado si quieres
puedes efectuar las operaciones para
verificar que en efecto estas
expresiones son estas dos que puse
entonces nos quedaría que el área es
igual a la raíz
la raíz de y vamos a poner las
expresiones con con estos cambios vale
sería además b al cuadrado más b al
cuadrado menos a perdona que además sea
al cuadrado verdad qué bueno que me di
cuenta además sea al cuadrado aquí
también sería a más sea al cuadrado
déjame borrarle para borrarle
porque sería a más que bueno que me di
cuenta porque si no luego no nos iba a
salir entonces esa masa al cuadrado
menos b al cuadrado dividido entre 4 x y
voy a poner b cuadrada b cuadrada menos
a menos sea al cuadrado
a menos ea al cuadrado dividido entre 4
vale déjame cerrar el paréntesis y
observa que una vez más aparecen estas
expresiones diferencias de cuadrados
aquí tenemos un cuadrado menos otro y
aquí un cuadrado menos otro entonces
podemos reescribir todo esto como la
raíz la raíz de la siguiente expresión
ya vamos a hacer todas las
multiplicaciones voy a ponerlo de
adentro con verde vamos a hacer las
multiplicaciones 4 x 4 es 16 entonces
aquí quedaría 16 pero fíjate lo voy a
poner como 2 por 2 por dos por dos
ahorita va a saber por qué entonces nos
quedaría imagínate que este es x y este
sería x +
qué es simplemente cambie tantito el
orden luego sería x x a más v x ahora es
este con este verdad x + sería b b más o
menos c x este menos éste ve - a menos
eso es lo mismo que ve más menos a muy
bien voy a extender tantito la línea de
la fracción cerramos el paréntesis de la
raíz y ahora sí vamos a separar cada uno
de estos entonces nos quedaría que es
igual a la raíz a la raíz de lo
siguiente d
entre 2 y que entonces es a b c entre 2
x ac - b entre 2
y se ve entre 2 x además ve - entre 2
b - c entre 2 y x b más c
menos a entre 2 y esto ya se empieza a
parecer un poco un poco más a la fórmula
de geron vamos a hacer los siguientes
cambios observa observa que esta
expresión
se ve también la podemos poner como a
más ve más o menos dos veces ve ve - 2b
- b de manera similar
además bm se está más ve más c menos dos
veces c y ve más o menos a es a b c
menos dos veces a dos veces a saleh
entonces vamos a reescribir utilizando
estas expresiones nos quedaría que es
igual
el área es igual a la raíz la raíz de lo
siguiente vamos a ver vamos a vamos a
prepararnos es más ve más entre 2 a b c
entre 2 vale esto lo voy a poner así
entre paréntesis x y ahora vamos a poner
esta expresión
más se ha dividido entre dos menos dos
veces b entre dos sería menos b - b de
manera similar
éste es más ve más c entre 2 menos a
porque es 12 entre 2 - perdón menos c 1
c y estoy acá sería además menos a
porque es 2a dividido entre dos o más b
más dividido entre dos menos a y esto es
exactamente la fórmula de heron solo que
recuerda que para la fórmula de heron
habíamos definido que ese era el semi
perímetro la mitad del perímetro a más b
más dividido entre 2 y claramente
claramente haciendo la sustitución con
esta variable nos queda que el área es
igual a la raíz a la raíz de ese s
voy así en color rosa está bien s x s b
x s menos y x s menos
s - ah y si recuerdas esto de aquí es
exactamente la fórmula que di en el
primer vídeo acerca de la fórmula de
heron está padrísimo no crees bueno nos
vemos en siguientes vídeos